so um bill o'reilly but yeah you know
like bill o'reilly like I like Bill
always go here - I hate all white people
take himself seriously
brookies the kuraki sir but he is always
going after rap as the reason for every
ill or full of that I outhouse
right I'm gonna go in a black Club and
see Bill O'Reilly with a stripper in his
lap I guarantee you that no no I don't
know where's all the books he writes as
what Paden would have done he and we
know it's an act
we know it's and I think the no you're
wrong I know bill that is not an act
bill is full of you know he may be
full of but is sincere really
of course people really think that way
what are you already have you can't up
thank you Mike Mike you're the one
living that means I'm gonna fight him
one day but but he bled this thing I was
just talking about the down the religion
like the Christians losing Christians he
blames that on rap music and I write
because like the least the people who
are least likely to leave Christianity
are black folks oh now you're not well
it stickler black women they not leaving
out my mama and sisters in ground well I
know Jesus to the end yeah this was like
the others would rather go right he
would use a arguably black guy or at
least dark hung with a posse of homies
one of them was strapped with a knife
went to war with the government lost
what I got of black guys do and um
everybody loved them more if he died
like Tupac
and he may not have existed at all
I agree uh-oh you know really why I did
I know three chart at the rights